with a big surprise credit scene and an
ingenious twist the Enola home sequel is
loaded with hidden Clues and bonus
Sherlock Easter eggs yippie kai movie
lovers I'm Jan and in this video I'm
explaining why we could well be getting
a new Sherlock spin-off plus all the
little details I spotted in the movie
you might have missed spoilers ahead of
course so take care by the end of the
movie Enola exposes a conspiracy that Mr
line and Lord McIntyre have been
covering up the deaths of workers at the
match Factory from white phosphorus
poisoning and blaming it on typhus
however there was a clue to what was
really going on very early in the film
when a girl with a disfigured jaw was
turned away from the factory this was a
real life condition that Afflicted
workers in the Matchstick industry at
the time and was known as Fosse jaw and
there's another early clue to this
conspiracy when Enola breaks into Mr
Lyon's office and discovers a box of
non-toxic red matches rather than the
white matches being made on the factory
floor so it looks like you wasn't
willing to even risk using the new white
matches himself but he'd let his workers
breathe in their fumes all day also
notice how the original red Matchbox
sold for two pennies whereas the white
matches sell for half the price a big
hint to how much cheaper the white
phosphorus really was
[Music]
but the next big twist comes when we
discover that McIntyre's secretary Miss
Troy is Sherlock's Nemesis Moriarty if
you spotted the Moriarty clue when she
revealed her full name to anola at the
ball give yourself a pat on the back
mirror Troy private secretary to Lord
McIntyre but what you might have missed
was an even sneakier clue earlier on
when Sherlock reveals a critical piece
of information about The Mastermind
behind the string of unauthorized money
transfers he's been investigating a week
before the first transfer there was a
break-in at the Treasury office by a man
in a taper Crown hat notice that the
first time we see Miss Troy she's the
only person wearing a tapered Crown hat
that means it Narrows as it goes up
whereas the other characters had to
untapered in other words the hats go up
straight talk about keeping Moriarty's
identity under her hat if you turn the
movie off as soon as the credits began
you'll have missed a crucial bonus
mid-credit scene in the scene Sherlock
is putting on his pipe ready to meet his
sister for their 4pm Thursday
appointment and but she's arranged for
John Watson to turn up instead Sherlock
had told Enola that she could be his
flat mate but she turned down his offer
in order to keep working independently
of her famous brother so instead she
told Dr Watson that Sherlock was looking
for a flatmate because remember she said
to her brother that she didn't think he
should be alone so much no one should be
alone all the time friend would do you
well it looks like this could be setting
up a potential spin-off movie or series
for Henry cavill's Sherlock I know a lot
of fans would like to see this and it
could be a good way for both Millie
Bobby Brown and Cavill to get plenty of
room to focus on their own characters in
separate movies while also crossing
paths from time to time let me know what
you think in the comments below and
leave a thumbs up if you'd like to see
this happen and with Sherlock's
increased screen time in the sequel we
get even more Sherlock Easter eggs the
film's production team really went to
town designing the look and feel of 221B
Baker Street they wanted to show how
this Sherlock is a slightly obsessive
collector and his untidy bachelor's pad
is full of skeletons of rare beasts
geological specimens fossils insects
microscopes and magnifying glasses
there's also a little tortoise figure on
Sherlock's floor holding down some
papers which feels like a nod to
Sherlock's Turtle Clyde in the CBS
series Elementary and perhaps also to
this little moment from the TV show I'm
pretty sure you shouldn't use Clyde as a
paperweight Sherlock's famous violin is
also prominently featured in the room
and he uses it briefly when he plays the
tune to a clue Enola found on May's body
a famous fiddle and there's an amusing
little interplay between lestrade and
Sherlock when he comes across Sherlock's
pipe take it take your account perhaps
okay the iconic pipe was teased in the
first film with this picture of him
puffing on it this is actually an 1891
sketch published in the man with the
twisted lip with Henry cavill's face
overlaid on the original image but the
beginning of the movie Enola is
struggling at her newly opened detective
agency while her brother's Fame
continues to rise
[Music]
the shout out to the very first Sherlock
Holmes book a study in Scarlet where he
investigates a murder in Brixton enola's
potential clients won't take her
seriously because of her gender and age
and she can't even get her due credit
for the case she solved in the first
movie took spruces well that was
Sherlock Holmes that was Sherlock
Sherlock Sherlock Holmes wasn't it she's
even mistaken for a secretary at one
point which is an Easter egg to the
original Enola homes novels where she
had to masquerade as a secretary in
order to pursue her vocation when Bessie
comes to Enola for help to investigate
her missing sister she shows a Nola's
newspaper ad for her detective agency
missing persons found this is a hat tip
to how in the books and Nola refers to
herself as a scientific purgatorian a
title she made up from the Latin word
perditus meaning lost or as a nola puts
it I'm a finder of lost souls by the way
the little toy that A nola dropped just
before Bessie came into the agency is
Dash a Nola's pet toy from the first
movie which Sherlock brought to her when
she was stuck at finishing school and
which she also left as a clue to
Sherlock at the very end of the first
film a bit of pine cone wrapped in Wool
dragged it with you wherever you went
calling it Dash hidden in the newspapers
that keep popping up are some great
secret jokes and details when Enola
talks about teaching a dog to sit the
movie cuts to an advert for Dr Pavlov's
patented Pooch Persuader approved by
socks the Wonder Dog this is an amusing
reference to physiologist Ivan Pavlov's
discovery that he could condition dogs
to salivate at the sound of a bell by
ringing a bell whenever they were shown
a plate of food after a while the dogs
Associated the bell sound with food and
salivated even if they weren't brought
any food these principles of classical
conditioning are popularly known as
Pavlov's dog
by the way if you pause here you'll see
that socks the Wonder Dog is actually a
regular performer at the Paragon Theater
where Sarah and may used to work and if
you pause the film right at this point
you can also spot an advert for a crazy
Contraption called an electropathic belt
which promises to cure weak and languid
feelings nervousness and rupture and
corpulence and general debility
amazingly this isn't a made-up joke for
the movie but a real device that was
sold in Victorian London by the medical
battery company in fact electric belts
and other pseudo-medical devices were
widely promoted around the time Enola
homes is set and they were touted as
being able to treat a vast array of
illnesses and conditions a huge exposure
was later run in The powmau Gazette the
newspaper that features in the movie and
which also had previously run numerous
ads for the very same belt and if you
watch all the way through the movie's
fancy credits you'll find some more
hidden in jokes in Easter eggs for the
filmmakers and crew there's an advert
for Brown and Brown Fine confectionery
with a photo of Millie Bobby Brown and
her dad Robert Brown both producers on
the movie and Springer's silver fountain
pens fine writing implements for the
scholar and Scribe is a reference to
Nancy Springer who wrote the original
Enola Holmes Mysteries book series
there's an ad for nuts and silver
nitrate Studios on the credit for
Director of Photography Giles nutgens
appropriately enough given that silver
nitrate is a chemical used to make film
stock and Millie Bobby Brown's sister
Paige gets a shout out via Brown's book
binders which might also be a reference
to how it was Paige who originally
proposed the idea of Milli playing the
part of a nola on screen after she
discovered the Enola homes books and if
you'd like to discover the biggest
changes made from the Enola homes books
for the movies and how they made Henry
Cavill Sherlock a lot more sympathetic
tap here to watch that video or follow
the link in the video description so
what did you do you think of Enola homes
too and are you hyped up to see more of
Henry Cavill Sherlock with Watson let me
know what you think below and if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to leave
a thumbs up and hit that subscribe
button and notification Bell to get more
videos just like this thanks for
enjoying this movie with me and hope you
have a marvelous movie loving week
yippee Kai movie lovers